hey I'm going to show you some video
that I would get the kids out of the
room this is extremely disturbing video
of Pastor Greg Locke from the global
vision Bible Church in Mount Juliet
Tennessee now the video that I am going
to play for you
um one
it's politically outrageous and crazy
I also don't know if this guy is having
a medical incident during this video I
don't know I'm not a neurologist but is
this a stroke is this guy because this
is out of this world crazy video during
which Greg Locke starts screaming to his
congregation by the way the the services
are taking place in a circus tent which
you you will see if you're watching
which is fitting he starts screaming at
his congregation not to get vaccinated
and that he was right about everything
what he's talking about I don't know but
let's take a look
wow I've been right about all of it whoa
we've been right about all of it
oh yes and you can see there that it is
literally in a circus tent a striped
circus tent
yes
these Wicked fools don't win in the end
they don't win in the end
so all this fear bull crap is that it is
bull crap Say Amen
I know you've never been to a church
where a pastor told you to say amen
after I said bullcrap
it's better than what I want to say
I'm like is this this this is is this a
psychotic break
is there any context outside of it a lot
of us see this and we say it doesn't
matter then it's that it's in a church
this is mental illness uh is there any
context outside of a church where you
would see this and not say whoa 72-hour
psych hold
I call it real BS biblical stupidity
biblical stupidity
so I know I wasn't gonna say nothing
about it but I think I feel froggy
enough I'm gonna jump right now and just
say this whoa
I am not
apologizing for what I said on this
platform last week
okay
the Delta variant was nonsense then it
is nonsense now you will not wear masks
in this church you will not wear a mask
in this church I'm telling you right now
do not get vaccinated do not get
vaccinated I I don't care what you think
about me he's getting a standing ovation
for this folks there's a pastor
excuse me in a circus tent
getting a standing ovation for saying no
masks allowed and you will not get
vaccinated don't need your money
I don't need your hand clap I don't need
more people on social media to follow me
Socha I ain't following along with it
Joe Biden's days are numbered
I said they're numbered
I've told you the whole time this
election was fraudulent okay this is a
cult this is a terrifying terrifying
cult even the term Pastor is like what
it's more like cult leader remember
that's that's a tax-exempt church that
is a churches are allowed to be
tax-exempt they're not supposed to do
politics he said the election was stolen
that's politics he should lose his tax
exemption will the IRS investigate
they're not investigating nearly enough
and then the anti-vaxx non-science
nonsense uh this same guy a week ago a
threatened to kick people out if they
wore a mask to his church same guy in
Mount Juliet Tennessee
Tennessee really low vaccination rate as
of yesterday uh 39.2 percent the
national average it's about 50 the
country is vaccinated about 50 Tennessee
is more than 10 points below that at 39
there are States you know Vermont's at
67 Massachusetts 64 Maine 63. Tennessee
is very lowly vaccinated very highly
infected and you have a tax-exempt
church pastor saying do not get
vaccinated Biden didn't really win
how is it that that can be tax exempt
how is it now but now on the other end
who thinks this guy's been vaccinated I
genuinely don't know could he be
vaccinated but he knows that these are
the types of rants that play to his
audience's fantasies and delusions
because a lot of these anti-vaxx members
of Congress that we've found out about
they are vaccinated or at least they
some of them are vaccinated some of them
don't want to say one way or the other I
think we know why
um absolute insanity and you know when
we when we try to understand
how did how do some people in this
country believe the stuff they believe
if you grow up around just that's your
one social thing where you go to a
church in a circus tent and that's what
you see
um and then all your co-workers are
going to that
and your parents growing up tell you
what you see in the media is not true
what you read in history books isn't
true that's how we end up with the
problem we have in this country so we'll
have more on that on our uh Show
Instagram make sure you're following us
on Instagram at davidpackman show uh
coming up after the break I'll be
speaking with Attorney Peter mouge that
26 billion dollar lawsuit against the
opioid Distributors and manufacturers
Peter muget is one of the attorneys who
negotiated it and we will talk to him
next